assalamu alayka what a missile I better
care to be bombers and sisters and dear
friends welcome to this video obviously
the title does seem bit controversial
but that was not my intentions in
instead my intentions was basically to
catch your attention because this is a
matter that's a big problem within the
Ummah and I thought I would discuss this
in detail obviously a lot of people
suffer from and unfortunately we have a
lot of judgmental people both practicing
individuals and non-practicing which I'm
going to touch up on inshallah but the
main reason I did this video was
obviously a sister that I knew not
personally who go in contact with our
team about a year a year - yeah a year
and a half ago who was basically
practicing the Deen who wore the net
carb who were the hijab she was
practicing a religion certain things
happened in her life major issues which
led her to taking off the niqab and the
hijab off well obviously we don't wanna
carry on any further before we actually
listen to the recording so what we're
gonna do is I'm just going to briefly a
two to three minute recording I want you
guys to listen to where she's coming
from initial I'm gonna discuss it
further
Salaam alaikum um here's my short
experience okay I used to be fully
veiled I struggled a lot with that with
family acceptance friends society
whatnot burn I was very into my religion
very intensely into the religion Islam
and I remember one night I was growing
up the mosque and I will atop why two
men I was abused that very night from
the boredom I'm just coolster awful
amount of damage I cannot explain the my
damage of cause dollar stores offering
and
affected my way of thinking and affected
how I dress
each drove me insane so then slowly well
no not slowly actually I remember I made
this decision while I was taking a bath
actually it's gin said you know what I
want a call right now I know that if I
take it all off things will be different
however I still want to take off but as
I take the the Fulvio loss and go back
to how I used to dress which is just
luck and you westernized girl would
dress all the sisters die I had close to
me many has left me a lot of people
online judge me not only me but judge a
lot of people who are not able to wear
I'm not really correct but earn and that
affects us a lot because it hurts you
don't know the troll or somebody you
don't I remember when I was on Dean
sometimes I was harsh to people in terms
of hijab and whatever and now when I see
other people do it to others and me
specially it affects me anything
Wow was that really how I was so I hope
you listen to this with the intention of
changing within by listen let my less
let my experience be a lesson to you
don't let the Dean don't let it harden
your heart don't let it make you Aragon
humble yourself just the way Alec would
give you the guy over and second he can
take it away even faster and it's hard
out here it's very hard on struggling a
lot especially for Muslim people all
around the world it's very judgmental -
not very supportive and it hurts because
you're meant to be my family do you know
what I mean yeah thank you for listening
you've heard it for yourself and
obviously everybody has their own
struggles in their different ways but
what really hit me and really really
like got to me with this sister story is
that the fact that
she's saying that when she's practicing
the religion where she's wearing the
niqab in the hijab she had sisters there
who said we are going through thick and
thin we are together
unfortunately these sisters didn't
really stick to their word which we do
not know why but it's sad that we have
practicing individuals practicing
sister's or practicing brothers with
this case is practicing sisters that
instead of helping the sister out of the
issue that she's gone through that has
led to this
she has indirectly and directly received
messages basically saying if you don't
wear the hijab or you're dressing up
these in certain ways you are a [ __ ]
this is the word that they're using
against her and this really really
touched me and really hurt me and that's
why I thought you know I need to make
this video because this is a growing
problem and this happens a lot you know
unfortunately surfing's I've witnessed
myself where individuals look down upon
me because of a certain way I dress
and that's why I thought the best way to
go about this is to address this
inshallah so this video can really
benefit you guys now one of the main
causes and reasons behind this is that
once an individual starts practicing the
religion and starts wearing the niqab or
her job or stop starts praying into an
extra place etc what happens and the
main cause of this is that arrogance
kicks in what is arrogance arrogance is
a trait of Shaitaan thinking that you
are better than another individual which
can be a variety of reasons Oh for
example is this color or on this color
or is from that caste and I'm from this
class he's from this tribe my tribe is
higher in the matters of Deen
individuals do the same thing as the
Shaitaan did so you are actually
carrying the Sunnah of the Shaitaan this
is what you are doing because you are
looking down at an individual why
because now the Oliphant Allah has
guided you to the right path externally
and maybe internally you think you have
the right to look down upon another
sister or another buff and say you know
what look at this person doesn't feel
like dress up like a [ __ ] or look at
this barber dressed up like a cool far
this is arrogance this is you know what
this actually means it means that you
are thinking you are guaranteed Jannah
you're going gender and what you're
doing is you're like ah look at these
guys man look at them selling out their
hereafter or look at them heading to the
Hellfire we
no from a narration of the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him where he says
an individual will live their life like
the people of Jannah and there will be a
hand span between him and Jana and what
is in himself overtakes him and he ends
up in the Hellfire by acting like the
people of the Hellfire and the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him says a
similar thing where he says there'll be
certain individuals who lived the life
of like the people of the Hellfire and
when is there is a hand span between him
and the Hellfire was deep in his heart
overtakes him and he starts acting like
the people of Jannah and he enters
Jannah now what do we learn from this
think about this really carefully this
shows us whoever it is we're in the Dawa
or you're a share or you're a scholar it
gives us no right to think hey I'm saved
Wael I have been like brothers and
sisters I don't know where I'm going to
be tomorrow
what lie I'm telling you I don't know
where I'm gonna be tomorrow I don't know
if I'm going to be a disbeliever I don't
know if I'm going to turn against Islam
and we have many examples I don't need
to give names individuals who were under
deed when you look at them like wow they
were strong and today you look at them
you're like whoa he's gone off the track
this should make us realize hold on a
second I'm not guaranteed general so who
do you think you are and I don't mean
this in a disrespectful way my dear
sister my dear brother who's practicing
the religion may Allah bless you guys
and make your path easy but who do you
think you are to look down at another
individual a sister that doesn't wear a
hijab or a brother does struggling in
certain ways with clothing or whatever
it may be one line who do you think you
are to look down at that person this is
arrogance this is you thinking you're
better nothing can hit me
I've got the ticket to Jannah always
giving me because I'm praying my solana
how do you know you're not going to stop
prayer praying salat tomorrow so what we
learn from this is my brothers and
sisters is to be humble always why do we
pray every day we pray every day asking
a lot to what Allah keep me on the sirat
al-mustaqim keep me on there you always
asking Allah for guidance always for
guidance forget you and me who are me
and you Prophet sallallaahu sent him
said oh the one who tosses and turns the
hearts around as you please as you will
keep my heart firm on the Deen the
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu wasallam
is making add water Allah and saying
he's making it what a lot to sit stay on
the right path and in
time when has ever the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him all the narrations
that we have from his life when has he
ever looked down upon individual and
said oh you're going to Hellfire you're
doing this or you're doing that even the
man who came and said o rasulallah
migizi not permissible for me what did
he do
hey you you're going to the Hellfire get
lost no he said sit down can you imagine
if today somebody came and said that to
us we would probably try to kill him so
that shows that we should learn
something about the character of the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him never
look down on anyone
prophet ibrahim ali salaam he's the one
who smashed the idols with his own hands
and we limited why said o allah divert
me from ever worshipping other than you
so we've got two prophets who are making
dua to Allah and asking for guidance and
whereas we ourselves what are we doing
we practice our religion little bit
think we're a little bit pious and what
do you do start spotting people are look
at him look at her hijab one like I've
had people telling me that another
sister in the car don't give me Salam or
all they know individual sisters we were
in a car and they've told if friends are
I don't give that sister salon why oh
because she wears any card like this
what seriously or a sister in hijab
mashallah look you wearing the correct
way but how could you walk past another
believer and not give them Salaam white
oh she's wearing trousers or jeans is it
wrong of course it's wrong nobody's
seeing what the way she's dressed is
right but it's arrogance on your behalf
to not give a Salam and drift them or
away just the way the system was drifted
away instead Salaam alaykum sister that
Salam that you might see to her maybe
she's going through some difficulty at
home she was here you know at least a
brother or a sister on the Dean has
acknowledged me I said salam-o-alaikum
you don't know how it can touch an
individual's heart always so we've
discussed that practice and individuals
are looking down and shown a division
saying you know you're a slot for not
wearing the hijab etc etc okay but then
we have the other extreme most other
extreme now we have sisters who don't
wear the hijab
they look at the sisters at where the
jab and go oh she's undercover halt now
this is another extreme now why you need
to understand sister look if you have
your own strong with an you can't wear
the hijab may Allah bless you may Allah
give you this courage and the strength
to do that
because you're not wearing a hijab it
does not give you any right to look down
upon them because yes you're right the
uniform represents something ambitious
step up to that standard I have nothing
to say to that you are right however you
can't look at a hijab a sister or a
brother in a foe and expect perfection
yes they should not seen in public I
want to be seen with you with that but
you can't look at them and say hey look
at her she's doing this don't pick on
everything because what happens is it
means that you have a disease in your
heart even Tamiya said it says some
individuals they are like flies they
have this disease in the heart where
they don't land on good places they look
for bad places like wounds you know and
they land on their so you need to
sometimes see the good in people to say
you know what this is at least trying to
wear the hijab at least she's trying
that brother is trying to lower his gaze
look at the good in people and don't
look down on them I say oh ah she's like
that you know what I don't wear the
hijab but you know I'm not like her what
I this is an excuse within yourself why
don't you be the better person
why don't you see you know what this is
the Western hijab she has a boyfriend
I'm going to wear the hijab and not have
a boyfriend so coming back to the main
point of practicing dividuals looking
down a non-practicing oh there's a lot
of people that don't wear the hijab or
outlook appearance they don't look
practicing but they do practice their
religion yeah and obviously they should
better their self by wearing the hijab
norming the gays for the brothers
brothers wearing the correct way of your
job this is very important is working
job is not just for the sisters so I
would oppose it they might not look like
whoa there they are Muslim but one lie
I'm telling you from a personal
experience I have seen sisters who were
correct with a buyer correct wear of
hijab and what lie the words that they
have uttered like they will see certain
words well like as a man I feel like
opening up the earth and going inside
for a few days and coming back out later
what lie I'm telling you as a man I feel
like you know what I just want to
disappear from this planet this
existence
I don't thinking how do you see that as
a sister who wear the hijab or a buyer
or a Aki who has a beard or for you I
would appear is important but some
individuals they don't have the inner
modesty the ania is not there the outer
appearance we got nothing to say
whereas we have certain individual soul
sisters they don't cover up the doorway
the hedge up modest dressed and they
have a good hundred
an amazing an amazing way they have an
amazing IR so obviously they committed
yourself and perfect yourself by wearing
the hijab and a sister who's wearing the
hijab that doesn't have that inner
modesty can perfect herself by having
that inner modesty and understanding
what Haier is and it's not just an outer
appearance and neither does it mean it's
just than anything they both go together
and obviously from this I don't want you
guys to think that every single hijab is
like this or every single not hijab is
like that nobody's saying that okay guys
so I don't want to keep you guys long I
want to wrap it up but once again I
really want to push push this point
really forward is that look if you see a
brother or sister who doesn't look in
the out outward appearance as a Muslim
you have a disease in your heart indeed
if you say to them are they don't look
like a Muslim look at this individual
look at the way of hijab that means you
have disease in your heart and you're
carrying the Sunnah of the Shaitaan
because you being arrogant and looking
down an individual based on what you
don't know nothing you don't know the
struggle that going through never forget
that at one point you didn't wear the
hijab as a brother you didn't use to
lower your gaze or pre so who gives you
the right to judge anybody and last but
not least brothers and sisters the
matter of slander don't forget that
every time you walk past the sister and
say oh she's done this or she's done
that or she's look at she doesn't wear
the hijab she's a [ __ ] or your your nun
hijab' and you look at her job insisting
go I look at she's a undercover ho an
undercover Hodja B these are all slander
these are all son that I lost want Allah
sent down revelation when they slander
happen against I should add allahu anhu
so you need to understand Quran came
down or Anne came down for the matter of
slander as